if you'd asked me 10 years ago when I
started my lab that I'll be you know I
have a one-kilometer tano and recording
from I call it whole colony of bats I'll
tell you you're nuts I'm studying the
hippocampal formation set of brain areas
that have to do with learning and memory
and I'm studying close brain areas in
somewhat unusual animal models in bass
[Music]
that's I think they are very cute the
bats that we worked with the Egyptian
fruit bats have these interesting
behaviors if we try to utilize and that
give advantages over the standard animal
models which are mice and rats so for
example if we want to add to ask
questions about how 3d space we
dimensional spaces representing the
brain bats are flying mammals so
obviously they're good choice for that
we can also another advantage is that
bats have two distal sensory systems
vision and a colocation we can a
trade-off these two senses and ask how
the same spaces are presented under
these two these two systems which are
difficult to do in rats or mice we also
have questions about how very large
spaces are represented in the brain so
we've built this long tunnel 200 meter
long and we are building this year and
even longer tunnel almost 1 kilometer
long and we have bats flying there you
know 100 120 times back and forth while
we record neurons in their brain and we
see you know very different
representation in this enormous space
[Music]
so we implant these small electrodes in
the bath that allow us to record the
activity of single neurons in those
brain areas and we have developed the
small wireless sector physiology devices
called neuro loggers that are really
small and sit on top of the animal which
allow us to record wirelessly in a bat
as its flying around and then we can
have them fly in a large flight room or
in various learning large-scale spaces
that we would have built and studied
their representation of space we can
also have that interacting and ask more
social questions on the bat
but I'm really interested in is the
neural basis of natural behaviors you
know neuroscience have traditionally
focused on either of course anesthetized
animals and was it don't behave at all
or if they're you know doing behaviors
they're doing highly controlled
behaviors you know lever pressing or
nose poking in some very you know 30
centimeter size box the big plus size of
side of it is it is highly controlled so
you can get very repeated very
controlled experiment the minus side of
it is it's very far removed from natural
behavior from what the brain evolved to
actually do outdoors and so I really
believe in addition to having those
highly controlled experiments we should
ideally record the same neurons or at
least from the same brain areas from an
animal behavior in a more natural
situation now that the technology allows
it that we have technology for wireless
sector physiology for recording for
freely moving animals you know from
Wireless optogenetics camera arrays with
microphone with movement sensors also
the devices were not available until few
years ago we can really study the the
neural basis of behavior for the first
time for real
[Music]
you